الثانيه بتكون محفوره في ذكريات البشر
صرنا 800 مليار شخص على الكوكب هذه السنه
[موسيقى]
في 2022
يصير في اوروبا من وقت الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
[موسيقى]
من شرطه الاخلاق
بديت معها مظاهرات كل مكان سببت اكثر من
450 حاله وفاه
وفي شرق اسيا هددت الصين تايوان هجوم عسكر
تويتر
44 مليار
قيمتها ثلاثه مليون دولار
هذه السنه جددت اسئله زياده عن مصير
الكوكب ففي العراق الاف العوائل يتركون
بيوتهم بسبت الجفاف في مصر زادت التوترات
اكثر مع اثيوبيا على حصه دولتين من نهر
النيل والنهار تتحول الارض قاحله في
اوروبا في اسوا ازمه جفاف من 500 سنه بعيد
عن الكوكب قطاع الفضاء
وبدات الصين اول رحلاتها لبناء محطات
الفضائيه ونجحت ناس الاول مره تغيير مسار
كويت رحلات برنامج اللي بيرجع الانسان
والاول مره بعد 50 سنه
من جانب ثاني تضخم وصل الاعلى مستوياته من
40 سنه نسمع عن مخاوف ركود السنه الجايه
وهذه السنه صارت فيه تغييرات واجد في
الحكومات حول العالم
[موسيقى]
وفي العراق
بن سعيد
في فلسطين قدام الكاميرات اغتال الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الصحفيه شيرين ابو عاقله
[موسيقى]
هذه السنه كانت الاكثر دمويه في فلسطين من
16 عام
تقتحم المستشفى وتعتدي على الشبان
في العالم فيه اول نسخه كاس عالم عربيه
ويلبس البطل في تتويجها بشت صارت مباراه
اللي اعتبرها الفيفا من اغرب تاريخ كاس
العالم لما فازت السعوديه على مرشح
البطوله
جنون الاخضر
كبرياء و الاخضر
اللي كنا معكم فيها فجر كل يوم في بركاز
الفجر قبل ما تخلص السنه بيوم وقع
كريستيانو رونالدو مع النصر